das hier ist ein echtes Wiener Schnitzel
und das ist gar nicht mal so schwer wie
du vielleicht denkst der erste Schritt
ist erstmal unser Öl heiß zu bekommen Z
dem gebe ich ein bisschen Butterschmalz
und darin Frittieren wir später nächster
step ist unser Schnitzel schön dünn zu
bekommen wenn ihr keinen Hammer habt
könnt ihr dafür auch einfach ein
Topfboden nehmen damit das Mehl gut
anheftet Rü ich ein bisschen Wasser
drauf und leg die einfach einmal in
unsere panierstraße so jetzt kommt unser
Schnitzel aus dem Mehl ins Ei und dann
aus dem Ei in die Semmelbrösel auch hier
wieder gucken dass es schön angedrückt
ist wenn unser Öl etwa 180° hat dann ist
die richtig ge Temperatur erreicht und
ich zeig das jetzt nur in der Pfanne
macht das ruhig in dem Topf weil dann
seid ihr ein bisschen weiter weg von
eurem Öl Schnitzel nehmen und vom Körper
weg ins Öl legen Zack und jetzt geht's
direkt los ein gutes Schnitzel suffliert
man nämlich das heißt wir hatten es
konstant in Bewegung s dass unser
Schnitzel die ganze Zeit von Öl
übergossen wird schaut mal an wie sich
hier schon die ersten Bläschen bilden
das ist einfach wunderschön nach der
Hälfte der Zeit wenden wir es WoW und
nach wenigen Minuten hat man ein echtes
Wiener Schnitzel